بالامتار يتقدمون بين منازل البلدات
الصغيره التي استعادتها في هجومها المضاد
تنفذ القوات الاوكرانيه عمليات تمشيط بحذر
صحيح ان القوات الروسيه تتراجعت من هنا
لكنها تدق المنطقه دون توقف وتحاول العوده
نضطر للاحتماء في احد المنازل انسحبت منه
القوات الروسيه من اول مجموعه من البلدات
جنوبيه
هذه بلده استروجوفا التي كانت محتله منذ
شهر مارس من العام الماضي وقد حرضت قبل
اسبوع فقط على يد القوات الاوكرانيه
يبدو واضحا ان الهجوم صاحبته اشتباكات
عنيفه حسمت المعركه هنا لكنها لم تبتعد
كثيرا
كانت القوات الروسيه تحتمي في هذا المنزل
وهذه بقايا طعامهم وبعد هجومنا تراجعت الى
بلده ماكاريفكا الملاصقه هناك تشتبك
قواتنا معها ونحاول التقدم لكنهم يقصفون
بالمدفعيه دون توقف
رائحه الموت في كل زاويه جنود الروس
وموالون لهم تركوا على قارعه الطرقات
وبقيت اثارهم في مواقع خسرها في اول
اسبوعين من الهجوم
الاوكرانين انسحب بعض الجنود وتركوا ما
تشاهدونه من طعام وصناديق اسلحه كما بقي
بعضهم هنا هذا قتيل روسي بقي هنا
واحده من اربع بلدات متلاصقه قرب الحدود
مع مقاطعه زابولوجيا جنوبيه شرقيه
اوكرانيا استعادتها القوات الاوكرانيه على
ضفاف نهر موكريالي دمرت القوات الروسيه
الجسور فوقه ما زاد من صعوبه التقدم ولجا
الاوكرانيون لبدائل مؤقته بين بلده واخرى
يتشابه المشهد لا مكان للسكان هنا بعد
المنازل والسيارات باتت اثرا بعد عين
والقصف لا يتوقف خلفه الكابتلال
تمكنت القوات الاوكرانيه اذا كما تقول من
استعاده السيطره على عدد من البلدات
المحدوده منذ بدء هجومها المضاد الا ان
ضراوه المعارك واستمرار القصف بشكل مكثف
من قبل القوات الروسيه على هذه البلدات
يجعل من الهجوم المضاد على ما يبدو
اكثر صعوبه حسن مسعود الجزيره